Hello. Welcome back.
We're
on June 16th, first discussion for
chapter five,
which is going to be
about predictive coding.
A great and large topic.
I'll bring up the first idea map.
And also
we can return to the chapter mapping.
So any first takes or summaries or just
experiences to share that anybody wants
to bring up and then we'll kind of get
into it.
Okay, raise your hand or or write in the
chat
uh if you want to add anything or or ask
anything. So let's just kind of
start at the whole book level, zoom into
where we're at for chapter five, look at
the idea map of chapter five and start
to get through the
um
formalisms and ideas.
And as traditional
leave onto Friston to actually deal with
the details. Just kidding.
Um
chapter five is bringing to a close the
first third of the book.
And we can recall the 2022 textbook
where the first half was the epistemic
and the second half was moving towards
the pragmatic and the applied.
And then there was the sort of like
continuous and discrete
double posture within each of those
sections.
The 2026 textbook is laid out slightly
differently.
There's three sections, fundamentals,
which is the fundamentals of the
fundamentals of the principles of the
free energy principle.
The second half or the second third is
the active inference core.
And then the third part is applications
and extensions.
So, we're bringing to a close this first
fundamental section, and we can see from
the dependency graph
that this is going to invoke what we've
learned all along the way in chapters 1
2 3 4.
So, chapter 1 was pretty qualitative.
That was like the philosophical thought
experiments about being secluded from
the world through an interface.
Imagine that.
The second chapter focused on this
question of hidden state estimation,
which is just the inference to an
unobserved variable through observed
variables.
The third
section combined learning and inference,
kind of thinking fast and thinking slow,
inferring fast, inferring slow in terms
of that
inference being like akin to the
feed-forward quick operation of a neural
net that has a fixed topology and
weights.
And learning being akin to the synaptic
or weight-based updating of a neural
network,
which extends in the structure learning
setting even into the topology of the
connections. But just at the learning
and inference layer, it's like slow and
faster updating of models. Or if you
want like model training, which is
learning, setting the weights of the
neural network, setting the parameters
of the linear regression, and then
inference, which is just the real-time
crack of the whip, like one new
observation comes in.
Now, given all my parameters, what is my
latent state estimate?
And that was mainly discussed in the
setting of perception. Like you get the
thermometer update, what's your belief
about the temperature in the room? You
get the light intensity, what's the
belief about the size of the food?
Oh, and I wasn't sharing my screen,
either.
Um
it's going to be dealt with seamlessly
though once we start to integrate action
because
it turns out that action is just another
latent causal state of the world. So
it's kind of pre-tucked in
subtly so
how we're going to deal with perception,
cognition, action, and external states,
the four components of the particular
partition within this unified hidden
state estimation framework where we're
going to be able to do learning and
inference
and or inference
and in the approximative setting
we're going to use variational Bayesian
inference
which is where we get these energy-based
models, these energy-based functionals
that are going to be like tractable
incrementally optimizable
ways
to fit
hidden state estimation
type
challenges whether you think of them
more computationally
like algorithmically or more like from a
cognitive or cognitive modeling or
mapping setting.
So that's what we got through
in the first four. It's like the
situation
the estimation challenge
the slow and the fast aspects of the
estimation challenge
and then variational Bayesian inference
as an energy-based method to accomplish
that estimation challenge.
Now we get to predictive coding which is
um
it's an interesting choice, maybe we can
discuss it about why it's in
fundamentals
because it's going to invoke
some
of the variational methods, but also
it's going to be a little bit more
opinionated in terms of like
architecture
and um
it's going to connect especially in the
summary that
closing section of the chapter
it's going to connect a lot with
neurobiology.
So like if we just look at the summary
in page 120,
and we just look at the first sentences,
we begin with the E form of VFE. So,
it's going to summarize starting with
that variational free energy kind of
connecting most closely to chapter four.
But then,
the second
paragraph continues with some
statistical assumptions that are used in
the chapter.
And then, the final paragraphs of the
summary are going to connect to certain
neural cells and architectures and the
Bayesian brain hypothesis.
So, it's a fundamental because it's a
historical antecedent and it's a little
bit more of an opinionated architecture.
And also something to really
build out our understanding of like what
is predictive coding, what is predictive
processing, how is it related to the
Bayesian brain. How is what anyone says
about the brain related to this generic
systems theory and active inference for
generic systems.
Okay. Now, we get to figure 5.1.
And also, yeah, please again, raise your
hand or write in the chat if you have
any question.
Figure 5 Yes, Magdalena, please.
>> Um
when you say opinionated,
um what criteria are you using to to
make that conclusion?
Thank you. Opinionated.
>> Opinionated like it says more than just
a generic
system partition. It's going to be used
to apply to, for example, retinal
circuits.
Not just be like an abstract system.
And um it's going to make some choices
about which families of distribution,
not like these are irreversible or or
hampering choices, but it's going to
make some
specified choices that we're going to
uncover
that aren't going to be variously like
simplifying or facilitating.
And they're all pretty clearly signed
posted out.
So but but but um I I
I wouldn't necessarily put predictive
coding as like
at the level of fundamentalness of like
matrix multiplication or variational
calculus.
It's not like it's a mathematical
subfield that's a precursor fundamental.
This is more like a fundamental
way that people have applied
these methods.
So let's kind of let's trace that though
cuz that's an important point.
Okay, so we we we we get dropped into
this labyrinth
at the end of chapter four.
Way back when.
And we have variational free energy
which in the previous times we discussed
the several forms. The um D E
G forms of F.
Here is an example of one of those
opinionations or assumptions, which is
the Dirac delta assumption about the
variational density.
And a Dirac delta is just a spike.
It's just like saying we're going to fit
one parameter
to this distribution and it's just going
to be like the data point itself. It's
going to be one number. It's an
interesting kind of quasi distribution
that's just an infinite spike
concentrated at one location.
And we'll talk about why and how the the
Dirac matters.
And that's going to lead to
certain
closed form
analytical, which is to say like
equation-based
Thank you. You can put that in the
errata section, Giacomo. Certain
equation-based ways
to talk about this
prediction error architecture,
which is going to jointly do learning
and inference
on
means and variances. And the variances
are going to be expressed in terms of
like their precision.
So, we're going to be like jointly
looking at where the mean
of different distributions are
and how wide they should be. More
precise being like a lower variance,
less precise being a wider variance, and
why that matters. And that's called
precision weighted.
So, again, we have this kind of two-knob
Etch A Sketch.
One of the knobs is just going to scoot
the mean center of the distribution
left or right.
The other knob is going to make the
distribution wider or narrower.
And through
these assumptions, like the Dirac delta
assumption about the variational density
and the Gaussian assumptions of the
likelihood and prior,
which are not massively constraining,
but it's just good to be clear about
where they are,
we're going to get to this nice sum of
precision-weighted squared prediction
errors.
And I I want to here go to
an important contrast,
which is the sum of squares, also known
as the L2 norm, in the setting of
fitting a classical linear regression.
So, like, this is the calisthenic you
want to have really under your belt
before heading up to precision-weighted
predictive coding architectures. So,
first, just like, talk about what is the
sum of squares doing here.
So, we have these different data points,
like, could be
heights and weights for a different
animal, or whatever it is, X and Y.
And we just have these blue five data
points.
And we're going to try to fit this
linear regression
that is the best fit to these data
points
under this L2 norm or the least sum of
squares.
And what that means is we're going to
shift Here we also have two knobs. We
can shift the intercept up or down.
That's the plus B
component or beta naught.
And then there's the coefficient, which
is the slope, which is like the MX
part of the Y = MX + B or in this sort
of notation it's the beta one
coefficient.
So, we have these two knobs. We can
shift the line up and down
and we can rotate the line so that it's
from flat to almost vertical and
everything in between.
And what the ordinary least squares
method is going to do
is iteratively tune those two different
knobs
so that the number that's being
minimized, which is the loss function
is the sum of squares. Which is to say
the residual
these residuals
to bring each of the real data points
onto the line, like to bring this point
from 2 7, which it really was
to 2 4 in this situation
that distance squared. So, here we have
1/2 squared plus 3 squared
plus 1 squared plus 2 squared plus 1.
And we can see that basically that's
going to quadratically penalize data
points that are far away.
So, this is where we get into the
secondary discussions around like
outliers moving the curve. Because you
might have like 100 thick flat data
points
and then there's one data point out of a
million. So, it's going to move the
whole curve
um
to be fit all the way up to swing to
kind of accommodate that one data point.
So, like yes, secondary considerations
of model pathologies, all things to
discuss.
But this is the sum of squares
and that's how we fit
the standard linear regression
by minimizing this loss term, which is
the L2 norm, which is the sum of
squares.
Something very similar is going to
happen in 5.1.
It's going to be a sum of
squares.
It's going to be a sum of residuals, sum
of errors, aka prediction errors.
And they're going to be weighted with a
coefficient before each of those
prediction errors by a precision.
So, if we go to here, it's like one more
term being added here.
Where it's like for each of these, we
could have a different precision.
So, for example, maybe this one
yes, it's 3 squared, 9
is its squared residual difference, but
maybe this one is only precision
weighted to 0.1 attention.
So, in this one, the precision weighted
sum of residual is just
0.9.
Whereas this one
is 0.5 residual, raw residual
so squared would be 0.25.
But let's just say we had a 100x
attention on it, so it'd be like 25.
So, in that situation where we have a
100x attention on this channel one
and 1/10 attention on channel two
the net loss function would would weight
this residual as 25 points, let's just
say
and this residual
which is on a first look larger
as 0.9.
So, in terms of how would those data
points contribute to model updating
you can imagine something like
plus 0.9 being like the total
surprise, which is what we're going to
bound with variational free energy,
and then what is going to be the
relative influence is going to be like
25 over 25.9
for this data point's surprisal,
and 0.9 over 25.9 for how much this data
point contributes to model updating.
So, definitely get two or six feet into
sum of squares in a linear regression
setting,
because what's going to happen in 5.1
is like that
in a more
generalized online
energy bounded setting
modulated by these precision
coefficients.
Which in the Bayesian brain and
predictive coding setting,
people associate
the primary fast inference
with like fast primary
neurotransmissions,
and attention or precision
with secondary neuromodulation like
dopamine.
Magdalena and then anyone else.
>> Could you go back to the figure? Just I
need to clarify something for myself.
Does the um regression line here on this
graph represent
the generative model that needs
updating?
And then the knobs you're referring to,
um and the variance has to do with
somehow, you know, you
So, what I'm trying to get at is the
reality represented by that graph, is it
that the generative model is the
regression line and the knobs are just
indicating something about how far away
from that generative model you are at?
>> Almost, but basically, yes. The
generative model
is structurally defined by
this equation, beta zero and beta one.
Those are parameters.
So, when we're fitting the model
parameters, which is learning,
to the data, which are the observations,
>> Yes.
>> that's where we're modifying these
knobs.
So, the blue point are the empirical
observations.
The form of the generative model is
observations equal
intercept plus coefficient multiplied by
latent state, which of course we don't
observe.
So, that when we get another Y,
we want to do the best we can on these
five data points,
so that when we get that sixth Y,
we're going to be least surprised about
if we were to have found out what its
true X were.
Overfitting is when you fool yourself to
fit the five data points well, and you
end up getting more surprised than you
needed to be on that sixth data point.
Underfitting is when you haven't
leveraged the information from these
five data points, and so your prediction
for the sixth one is simply
ill-informed. Enter.
>> Yeah, uh I just also wanted to answer
the question. I This is slightly
reiterating what Daniel said in a
different way, um but just to hopefully
directly address if that wasn't um if if
you still have uncertainty. Uh the line
itself is the generative model. Uh to
answer that point-blank, um what defines
how high up that line is from zero, like
the reason why it starts at three on the
left, is that's our intercept parameter.
It's just going to determine how high or
low that line is sort of placed on the
graph. Uh the slope, as you know, is
like the curvature of the line. You
know, if it were uh directly horizontal,
it would have zero slope. Uh it wouldn't
be kind of changing up or down over from
it as we go from left to right. Um so
that's essentially what we're doing.
We're
a linear
a linear model like this is just a
straight line where you can adjust the
intercept by going up and down, and you
can adjust the the slope or the
curvature of it um with uh the beta one
parameter. So the it's the it's the
intercept and the slope that you're kind
of revising in order to better fit. And
then everything [clears throat] else
that that Daniel made points about
regarding like overfitting, etc. kind of
follows from that. Like if we imagine
like, "Oh, maybe we could make instead
of a straight line, we could make an uh
a non-linear function or non-linear
model that actually like curves up and
down." Um and then that way it could hit
every single one of those dots, those
dots being the actual observations, the
the this actual data, the Y that we're
receiving, the Y values. Um so if you
had that non-linear line going through,
uh and and that's your model, then it
would appear as if you could achieve
like a perfect model that can predict
anything. But of course, if you do that,
then once you get a new dot, um it might
lie way off of that line, uh in which
case like your model no longer
generalizes to circumstances beyond what
you've already seen.
Um which is uh yeah, as he said, like a
major issue in in machine in machine
learning and elsewhere that um we're
we're frequently trying to overcome. And
so there is like a a potential benefit
of having these kinds of like simpler
models if they're better at generalizing
to more data as opposed to making
something so hyper-specific that it
suddenly becomes useless uh whenever you
change the context or get data that you
haven't seen before.
>> Yep. Like in this situation, you might
be tempted and and it might not be the
wrong idea to do like a X to the third
polynomial.
So it just truly goes through each of
those points.
And then model selection is when you
look at, okay, we have a we have the
zeroth order polynomial approximation,
which is just a flat line going through
five.
That then we have the first-order
polynomial, which is a linear
regression.
Then we have a quartic. So, should it be
a ball going up or should a ball be
going down? Then we have x to the third.
And and and then like each of those you
can compare and ask basically accuracy
minus complexity.
How well am I explaining the data in
sample and out of sample?
How much am I penalizing extra
parameters?
So, that's model selection among
structurally different generative
models.
That's that third layer learning. So,
inference is like the fastest flow
through.
Everything is fixed. All the neurons are
weighted and fixed, and we just flow
through one flash.
Learning is slower, where we're
structurally fixed,
but we're going to adjust
quantitatively.
So, adjust geometrically but not
topologically.
And then the third layer of learning,
which is like structure learning, would
correspond to like new synapses forming
or new cells being brought in or cells
being pruned.
That's the slowest of the layers.
Um
an- another aspect that I'm going to
return to the um
chart here
is
I will share.
And this is brought up on page 102,
which is
the
now classical, but of course
extra-classically describing Rao and
Ballard 1999.
So, it's kind of interesting. Like, it's
like, well, where's predictive coding or
what's the empirical evidence? It's
like, I mean,
it's system by system what extent that
a given
behavioral system has been modeled
making unique explanations and
predictions and so on, but
this has been one of the most cited and
relevant works,
which is basically um
looking at visual input
and helping explain what were called
extra-classical receptive field effects.
Classical receptive field effects were
just like the information comes in, it's
just getting passed on in a processing
setting.
Extra-classical, which were error terms,
if you think of like a Kunian paradigm
sense, in the classical setting,
and Rao and Ballard showed
extra-classical receptive field effects
have to do with predictive coding in the
visual cortex.
So, that gave a functional
interpretation to what were otherwise
unexplained error patterns from the
classical feedforward model.
So, that showed that there's like
a neurological signal corresponding to
statistical aspects
of predictive modeling.
And since then, there's been so many
studies
mapping different
neuro phenomena, like from blood flow
through the fMRI,
through EEG,
and the wave patterns, like
there's just there's too many examples
to even mention of this, but that is a
broader part of like mathematical
computational
neuroscience or systems bio bio or
psychiatry is to map
uh
different statistical features
of different models to different
observed biological phenomena.
Okay, Adam wrote,
"Do you extend those layers to
adaptation or evolution?" Okay, so let's
just really quickly, let's say we have
that fast flow-through inference. We
have
synaptic weight updating learning,
and then we have a third layer that
relates to like structure learning.
Now, you can zoom out to the organism
level and go, "Okay, now we have this
whole trajectory
the
kind of like the Waddington's landscape
of a given organism's life
in its ontogenesis.
And then we have populations of those
which are in their own
adaptation
dialectic with the environment
with differential success of populations
based upon generational turnover,
natural history, all that.
Okay.
So,
we're going to get there, but it's I
think these are these are good context
to to have like kind of qualitatively
before we start to jump into these
equations because we're going to really
quickly go from
the free energy functional that we were
introduced to in the previous chapter to
the specific details of the prediction
error.
Um there are two kinds of prediction
errors.
State
and sensory, which is basically going to
correspond to your prediction error
about the x-axis, the latent unobserved
and the y, which is the observed
component of that.
Between 5.1 and 5.2
we're going to come to understand that
we can make a certain important
simplification of that variational free
energy. Which is like, we're not always
or even usually concerned with the
actual specific absolute variational
free energy.
Like, first off, it's very generative
model specific. Variational free
energies can't be compared even for the
same system
with two different generative models
that have different number of
parameters. And the second thing is
like, let's just say that it's
9,700
or it's
13.
Don't need to go too We get deep into
the numerology here, but the number
specifically does not usually matter.
What's interesting is the gradients.
And so here we're going to focus in on
the gradients of VFE. WRT means with
respect to
mu of X, which is just the mean estimate
of that latent state X.
So we're just going to be focusing on
like, yes, we want to figure out how
variable things are, how much precision,
attention, variance, entropy, all those
ways to talk about confidence,
uncertainty.
However, we're tracking the bulk. You
know, it's good to know if that baseball
coming towards you, is it wobbling a lot
or is it wobbling a little? Is it truly
wobbling or is it your eyes are
wobbling?
However, where do you want to put your
glove?
Right in the center of mass where it's
coming. So that is the central limit
theorem, basically, which is like
variance estimation is so critical,
sometimes it's even in intrinsically
important and a finding for your paper
or whatever.
But
when it comes down to
where should we put that central
tendency?
That is just looking at the mean
updating.
And for that update, it turns out that
we can actually just focus on the
gradients of free energy.
Like
the fact that we're at 5,000 m or 1,000
m above sea level or 500 m below sea
level
might not matter, for example, to know
which way to go.
It might be more important just locally.
Are we going uphill or we going
downhill?
Or which one of in in the nine
directions that I could go
or in however many whatever radial
direction I want to go
what is the gradient?
And then
that is used in optimization
incrementally.
And then in 5 2 3 and 4, we're going to
get introduced to this basically quick
progression
of sophistication of of predictive
coding methods, which is 5.2 is going to
be simple predictive coding for a single
parameter or single
modality.
5.3 is going to go into the multivariate
setting,
which basically just indexes on another
dimension.
Previously, we were doing predictive
coding on the temperature. Now, we're
going to do it on temperature and
humidity.
And temperature and humidity and the
level of light.
So, just separate modalities in a
multivariate setting.
And then 5.4
is going to go into where a lot of
people just like intuitively
are or get to or even begin, which is
like we have this hierarchical sense of
like, "Okay, we're doing phoneme
isolation from sound and then word
identification from phonemes and
sentences and the narrative and the It's
like, "Yes,
that's the hierarchical model
where we can talk about partitioning of
these like multi-scale bottom-up
top-down,
but that's what this textbook is about
is really zooming in like, "What are the
mechanics of just one dimension, one
variable predictive coding?"
And then once you have the software
to do that one,
you're just a prompt away from saying,
"Okay, now extend it into this and that
and set it."
Okay.
Um still on page 102. So, that main
paragraph on 102
is some good context by Numjoshi
about early like 1999 to 2005 era how
Raoul Ballard predictive coding models
and Friston et al.'s work in
neuroimaging, sensor fusion, data
modeling, all these topics
were getting brought together. And then
he says, "These papers lay out the
foundations for what would eventually
become the continuous state-space
formulation
of active inference framework.
Due to many modifications and changes
that Friston made in these papers and
those that followed, the model discussed
here is not strictly speaking predictive
coding in the original form from the Rao
and Ballard 1999 paper.
Rather, we'll see predictive coding can
be interpreted as a special case of
continuous state-space formulation
formulation of AIF.
One can also reasonably claim the
continuous state-space formulation of
AIF is completely consistent with the
main principles and ideas of predictive
coding, which is why these two terms are
sometimes, perhaps imprecisely, used
interchangeably in the AIF literature."
And then the beginning of the next
paragraph says,
"Importantly, this chapter will also
uncover a central,  tension,
that is present in many active inference
models. Informally stated, the tension
asks the question,
ought we le- ought we to leave our prior
model unchanged or change it in light of
new sensory observations? In other
words,
how should the agent proceed when its
model's predictions are in conflict with
the data that it is sensing?"
So, we're going to tackle that at like
the micro level, just the thermometer
readings coming in and our beliefs about
temperature.
But then you can think about that in a
hierarchical setting, like
how does that
shirt color that I think I saw that
person wear relate to my narrative
understanding of myself? Like, it can
get
into more symbolic and abstracted
cultural, experiential
domains.
But the
gears turning and the rubber hitting the
road on the algorithm is what is going
to get focused on in like 5.1 here.
Um
top of 103. This tension is at the heart
of active inference.
When extended to hierarchical models,
the theme is rewritten in terms of
tension between a top-down prior from
the layer above
meeting bottom-up sensory input
incoming from the layer below.
It's all Now, it doesn't even have to be
top and that's just one spatialization.
And a convention where the top is like
the more slower, generic prediction
provider.
And then the bottom-up are like the
up-rushing sensory observations, but
that's just one spatialization. There's
no reason why it has to be like
bottom-up or top-down. It doesn't have
to do with tops or bottoms.
Okay.
So, now we get into 5.1. But any just
general comments or questions or
anything anybody wants to add before we
go to
5.1.
Okay. So, 5.1
as we can sort of see
from this labyrinth here, it's all of
the left stuff. So, 5.1's going to be a
pretty chunky section.
But it's going to prepare us to
understand 5.2
with basically
gradient-based updating, 5.3 the
multivariate extension, 5.4 the
hierarchical extension. So, 5.1 is kind
of where it's at for like the real micro
details of predictive
coding.
Okay. So,
um
5.1.
The focus The main focus is this
section.
Let's add a little quick errata there.
Isn't it Isn't it amazing? Like it just
shows how And there's been great models
of active inference models of reading.
Let's just see if we already have that
one. Page 103.
Yeah, it's like you can read it a
hundred times. You can read it a
thousand times because you see
with your mind.
But then you come across a sentence like
the main focus is this section.
But it's not seen as a typo by the mind.
And you can even have thousands of
people look at that. That just shows you
how priors work.
Main
focus is this section.
in this
section.
So then there's like the sort of duck
rabbit and the ballerina illusions
that are sort of like so baked into our
priors
that we can't unsee it.
And then there's other situations where
once you see it, you can't unsee it.
But again, those are all the fun
situations that we get at our personal
level of access.
Anyways, we're trying to develop a good
intuition for this concept of
prediction error minimization. And like
you can kind of put those three pieces
together by themselves. Prediction is
what you believe before you find out.
Error is a discrepancy or difference
between what you thought was going to
happen with your prediction and then
what you observe.
And then minimization is some approach
which is going to be gradient based to
minimizing that.
Thus our goal is to re-examine the
content from the last four chapters in
light of this prediction error
minimization perspective.
And then the side note four is just a
reminder. The Rao and Ballard 1999 was
not formulated in terms of VFE.
That was something that was introduced
by Friston and others.
Okay. So,
um equation 5.1
is going to bring back the [snorts] E
form, which is the energy minus entropy
or negative energy plus entropy
form of VFE. [snorts]
Um
This is This is the sort of bathtub
style of reading. Just Look at the first
paragraph
and then look at the last sentence.
So,
right below 5.1.
We will be performing variational
inference under fixed-form Gaussian
assumptions, which means Q of X is
assumed to be Gaussian.
Which isn't an overly
burdensome approximation. Again, the
central limit theorem
makes many Gaussian assumptions.
Many Gaussian assumptions are They're
not just empirically justified. They're
also justified by the CLT,
which is just like it will get Gaussian.
Not necessarily a simple or first-order
or naive Gaussian, but if you have
certain not overly esoteric
statistical assumptions
or generating constraints,
you will get Gaussian-like behavior.
Where you can track the central
tendency. You're not going to get like a
bimodal kind of like a camel shape.
Okay.
Then,
dot dot dot
The energy term is actually an expected
value.
Let's just see if we have these
equations.
Up.
Okay. Thank you, Andrew, for adding the
equations.
So,
the energy term is an expected value.
So, we can rewrite
this VFE as 5.2.
Um
This is where the Dirac assumption is
going to come into play.
So,
the Dirac delta, again, just to get a
image of it up on the screen, it's just
a spike.
It's kind of like
>> [laughter]
>> It's like the exception that proves the
rule for statistical distributions.
Another cool way to think about it is
like statistical distributions are
waveform, and the Dirac delta is like a
particle.
So, sometimes you have ways to go from
the wave to the particle, which is like
a data point, you know, the the the
size the temperature is 72 plus or minus
4, it's like a wave. And then you get
the observation, and it's like the
delta.
That's going from like a particle
collapsed or from a wave collapsed to a
particle. And then there's times you go
the other way, which is like from this
particle, one or more that I have,
what's the wave that generated those?
So, it's kind of going back and forth
between the wave and the particle, which
doesn't need an overly quantum
interpretation, but but it it it does.
Um
So, between 5.2 and 5.3,
we're indicating that we're evaluating
the probability density at X
equals
mu sub X, which is this part here.
Act We're taking it right there. This is
where conditioning on
X being a certain value, the mean value.
Just taking the a stab right there,
Y.
So, you took like the kind of whole
chessboard of the joint distributions of
all X over all Y, and we're just
clamping X to be mu sub X.
And then we're going to ask about a
distribution related to that.
Taking expected value over a point mass
eliminates the expectation since the
um
the delta of X minus mu of X will always
return mu of X.
We're left with this
following.
Um
MAP will um remember the the maximum a
posteriori a posteriori
estimation.
So, this is basically the the maximum
likelihood
log likelihood estimate.
And
we use this quantity in chapter two to
determine the maximum
a posteriori little tiny typo right
there with a space after before MAP at
the top of 104.
Estimate for X evaluated at mu of X.
As we've done previously, we'll define
the mean of the log likelihood to be
generated with some arbitrary generating
function
GM
of mu. So, generative model of mu.
Okay. Now, we get to 5.4 A and B.
Okay.
This was not exactly
the full equation, but it's very very
close.
Um
the 5.4
is read like
P of Y given that X is X mu
is going to be defined as a normal
distribution
with those attributes.
And then
we can um kind of
that's the likelihood of a given data
point
given
X being that way.
And then we can kind of
step outside of that data points
likelihood
by just focusing on the prior.
Which is just
what's the likelihood that X is that
value?
And it's going to be a normal with these
attributes.
Um
then following the chapter two logic
those Gaussian equations come together
to obtain 5 5.
I think there's a few good steps that we
could we could kind of expand out
because there's some definitely some
some
um important
jumps and combinations there.
We've gathered together all the
constants as usual.
So this is a move that comes up all the
time.
It's just like
constants and then like variables. And
sometimes you can just continue to
separate out the constants
or ignore them or just focus on the
gradients to to disregard them entirely.
And the the terms that get squared in
the numerator so on the top
parts
of those two
um
the
E Y
and E X.
Here's here's the constant terms.
Those two terms that are square in the
numerator are the prediction errors.
So E Y
is going to be
the sensory prediction error.
So it's like this was a long journey
to get to
error fancy E of Y is the Y that you got
minus
what you believe the generating function
was given the latent state.
So, I believed that my belief was mu mu
of X.
And so, because of how I believe that G
transforms mu of X's into Y,
I had a certain belief about what was
going to happen
about the observation. And then we got
the real observation. And so, if
this was correct, either, you know,
broken clock correct twice a day,
or whether it was just a well-trained
model or whatever,
what is the minimum this could be? Zero.
Um it
you could think about an absolute value
term.
Like um but like if for the absolute
prediction error,
but this is just the regular prediction
error. So, it could be a positive number
if you overshot, it could be a negative
number if you undershot.
Um
and then the
uh so, that's the sensory prediction
error, which is uh that's the bullet
point. The difference between the actual
observation, Y = Y hat, and the model's
expectation of the observation under the
generating function.
So,
some of those steps you look back and
it's like, wait, we had to do what to
get to this kind of obvious point of
just being like a discrepancy between
our belief and the observation, but it
did matter.
And then the second bullet point on 104,
the state prediction error is the
difference between a prior belief about
the hidden state
and the most likely hidden state.
So, prior belief about the hidden state
is M sub X.
And then
mu sub X is
the
post-observation updated latent state
belief.
And remember that the latent state
and the observation, they could be kind
of in the same domain. Like we could
say, oh, it's like the true temperature
in the room and then the thermometer
reading, which is like a temperature
measure.
But also they could be totally
different. Like the latent state could
be is it day or night. And then the
observation could be the temperature.
So it's not that they even have to be on
the same
type of variable. One could be a
discrete and one could be continuous or
so on.
Okay.
So
that is the sensory prediction error
and the state prediction errors.
Our
prior and updated latent state beliefs
are our state prediction errors
which we update our beliefs based upon.
And then our sensory prediction errors
are our
expectations about observations
residualed against the observations as
they actually came in.
5 7
enter.
>> Yeah, if you
you don't mind me briefly chiming in.
Yeah, it it's like um just a couple
comments on the things we've come up
against so far. So I think in in
plainest terms from looking at these two
equations 5.6a and 5.6b, Daniel's still
already captured most of this, but just
reading it plainly. So this um
5.6a if we read it from left to right,
we're essentially saying
your
um prediction error for observations,
which is Y equals what actually happened
minus what you thought you would
observe. Like what the Y is what you
actually observed minus this G of mu of
X meaning this is the generating
function in your model that says um
given your state estimates, given your
parameters, all the rest, this is the Y
you thought would happen. So it's just
actual minus uh prediction. And then we
get that same exact formula for for
state estimation, right? And then we can
see how like whenever we have prediction
errors for like multiple terms in our
model, it it kind of just highlights the
significance of how all these things are
sort of interconnected, and you can you
can sort of have a model that's that's
relatively accurate in certain areas,
but not so much in others. Like if you
have predict very [clears throat] high
prediction errors for observations, but
very low ones for state estimations,
which might almost start to look kind of
pathological because you you're doing a
really good job at like
inferring what you thought you would
infer, but you're totally
misunderstanding the data in the first
place. So, you can have all these
interesting things that kind of come out
of that. And then another brief comment
on the Dirac delta function, which which
is backtracking just slightly, but it's
we we saw things that started to look
like it in previous chapters, and it
kind of as far as we're looking at these
normal or Gaussian distributions, the
big thing with the Dirac is that you
could almost imagine like what if there
was no variance, right? With the
Gaussian, we know that we have a mean
and a variance parameters, but imagine
there was no variance, meaning all data
that we ever receive just hits this
singular point, right? So, if you took
that what usually looks like a nice like
hill normal distribution, imagine the
variance shrinking shrinking shrinking
down until it's virtually zero. Now, it
just looks like this perfectly precise
straight line. And we had this
interesting question last Friday where
someone said like, "Oh, if you take this
like mean value of a Gaussian and things
like that, are you not just compressing
a lot of information?" And in a sense,
you are, right? You're compressing
anything if you only look at that mean
value, which by the way, the mean and
the median and the mode are all
equivalent when we're looking at like a
perfectly Gaussian perfectly Gaussian
distribution like that. If we shrink the
variance all the way down, we we are
kind of technically compressing a lot of
info, which is just of like with the
with the baseball example that Daniel
gave earlier, just like, well, we're we
need to get our mitt right where we
think the ball is going to go. Like, we
have to like end up estimating to a
point somewhere. While it's great to be
able to have the entire understanding of
the distribution because it captures a
lot of things about uncertainty, um
ultimately, whenever it comes to like a
lot of minute decision-making and things
like that, there are theories that we
tend towards kind of this sort of
compression. So, I don't want to get um
say too much more than that. Um but
yeah.
>> Good comment, though. The Dirac delta is
the infinite precision Gaussian
asymptote.
And then just like in this last little
section on the top of 105 before we get
to the example.
So,
in 5.7
A and B,
he writes, "We've rewritten the equation
in terms of precision,
which is the inverse of variance." So,
again, there's like so many terms that
people
will use, ranging from like just various
levels of formality, various levels of
statistics to physics kind of continuum
and ontology.
But, importantly, we have this lambda,
which is basically 1 / the variance. So,
when the variance is high,
the precision is low.
When the precision is high, the variance
is low.
>> [gasps]
>> And so, we can then say that our
constrained VFE loss function is defined
in terms of the precision-weighted
squared sum of the prediction errors
and the log of the variance of the
likelihood and priors. So, we'll call
lambda
epsilon squared lambda fancy E squared
a squared precision-weighted prediction
error.
We will sometimes utilize just the
squared prediction errors themselves
without weighting as they also carry
interesting information. So,
yes,
we got there.
Which is we're still just talking about
these two
prediction errors.
We're not talking about multiple
modalities yet, like sight and smell and
taste. Single
modality.
X and Y.
We have a prediction error for each of
them.
And then we're going to be able to
separately tune the precision, which is
to say the variance on them.
And then in the sort of situation where
they're both given an equal value,
you can think about that error profile
being spherical.
And then the situation where one of them
is like more precision than the other,
it's more like an oval.
And that is the precision weighted,
which is again
equivalent to saying variance weighted
once you correct for that inverse.
It's the precision weighted
prediction error.
S [snorts]
whether we're focused on the observation
prediction error and or the state
prediction error.
And from that point on, we will move
interchangeably between formulations of
VFE in terms of precision weighted
prediction errors. Again, where we can
change the precision on the X and the Y
separately.
And the equivalent variance weighted
prediction errors.
Which is like, let's just put both of
them as the same.
And then we'll have like a spherical
error profile, so to speak.
And not need to have a specific
precision for each of those separately.
Which is what happens in 5.1.
But that's just a a sort of simplified
take
to to
remove that extra layer of notation to
get at in 5.1 example,
the relationship between VFE and
prediction error.
Just so that we can get at that
relationship more clearly without this
um double precision modulation setting.
Okay. If anyone has a last comment, go
for it. Otherwise, I'll close the
recording there.
Andrew, go for it.
>> It's a really quick one. This is
something that's come up many in a lot
of more speculative conversations with
other people about like, oh, uh it
there's there seems to be a an
assumption that some people make that
prediction errors are necessarily bad.
And this is way down the line
in reading this textbook, but it's
worthwhile to know like they're not
always necessarily a bad thing.
For especially in the instance where
like you have a living organism who's
operating in a real world, like even me,
if I want to move my arm like to grab
something, like I'm predicting that I'm
going to do something. I need something
like prediction error along the way to
tell me, oh, my hand is not where I want
it to be yet, right? Like it think about
prediction error more as something that
helps with coordination
and understanding rather than something
that's purely outright always either
good or or bad thing.
And you know, we'll learn a lot more as
we go through the textbook, but I just I
wanted to throw that out there like it's
not always necessarily awful if you have
prediction error, but there are a lot of
other conversations that could be had
about that. Yeah.
>> Yes, good comment. Magdalena?
Unmute then go for it.
>> Yeah, Mike what so to be clear for
myself, you are saying that in the
discussion today, the assumption is that
we're dealing with one decision, right?
We're not dealing with hierarchical
decisions, multiple decisions, none of
that. It's just one decision.
>> We're not even at a decision yet unless
you think of your belief updating in a
perceptual setting as a decision. So, if
you think that's a decision, then yes,
our belief updating is a decision, but
if we're talking about like embodied
action, we're not even at that level.
>> Uh okay. I'm just okay. So, it's a
semantic So, I thought in embodied
cognition decisions are decisions.
>> Yes, and like the the difference is
right now when we're just updating our
beliefs about like the location of the
baseball.
>> Okay.
>> But not our actions.
We're not having causal efficacy in the
world. That's what's going to
differentiate action as a belief that
gets embodied and enacted. But right now
we're just think we're just like a sort
of passive spectator
observing stimuli
and doing precision weighted belief
updating, which could be consequential.
We know it's going to be consequential
in the full loop. But we're just focused
on that book prior
top-down meeting the bottom-up sensory
info, not on the organism doing action
selection as policy inference.
>> Okay. My my question that is
what you're showing here is I would say
a the structure of a decision-making
engine
that is this This is an engine that sits
in one mind,
not in multiple minds. Is that clear in
the math?
>> I would say it's the structure of a
belief updating equation,
>> Mhm.
>> which could apply to perception and or
action
that is ontologically unspecified
because we could be talking about
precision waiting as like a group's
evaluation.
So, this is not a statement about the
physical partitioning of the embodiment
or what we declare as a mind or anything
like that.
It's just like for example a macro
descriptor of a of a belief updating
system.
>> So, okay. My last question just for
clarification.
Um
in the process of going through all of
this, we are it this is ontologically
specified, but it is specified with
respect to a decision-making something
unit of a unit.
>> Like the modeler had to part had to
specify their system of interest
already.
So, it wasn't like this was just like a
waiting waiting to be objectively
unilaterally discovered by itself. This
was a modeler making a certain system of
interest scope. Now, they're talking
about some parameters in their
generative model. This is like steps and
steps away from a claim or a restriction
about what the real-world system is.
>> Thank you. Thank you.
>> I
Yeah,
just trying to like making it abundantly
clear we're not talking about decisions.
Like that
everything up to this point up to
chapter five there's been nothing about
decisions. There's been nothing about
action. There's been nothing about
you know, how how do I do something and
how did I come to that decision?
Um what what we do see are this is this
matter of beliefs.
And so so in another
vein,
um like sort of if
speaking of like like Koonian traditions
or otherwise like for a very long time a
lot of psychology and neuroscience for
decades was more centered around
perception and leaving off action or at
least conceiving of it in a different
way than what active inference does and
a lot of others who do things like
embodied cognition and the rest do,
which is where we actually make action
this this more explicit thing that we
have to be concerned with and making
decision-making something that we're
actually like concerned with and and
treat more fully. So, so in the past
it's been there's been this bias of
people as or the brain or otherwise is
sort of like a passive observer, which
kind of aligns with what we've been
talking about this far. You receive
observations and you it it leads to some
kind of update of your beliefs, right?
And that just kind of keeps happening.
And and even worse still, it tended to
be considered to be a one-way. It was
kind of like an empiricist sort of bias
that that we just sort of receive the
observations and there's some sort of
update that happens, but then over time
it's become recognized that it's it's
two-way that we have prior beliefs and
that those actually as far as visual
perception and all the rest, a lot of
what we see
is in some ways like a kind of a kind of
mixture of the real observation with
what we already expect it to be. Some
people have used the phrase of like a
hallucination or like a controlled
hallucination or otherwise.
You know, one thing is that like just
based on our retinal cells and and
cornea and the rest,
we can't actually see in color in our
peripheral vision. So, if you notice in
your peripheral vision anything looks
like it's in color, that's your brain
like filling in those gaps, right? So,
that that's the the bidirectionality of
this. We're still only talking about
perception though. We're still not
talking about actions and how do I do
things in the world. So, in later
chapters we will definitely get into all
these things about decision-making, but
I think I'm I just want to caution that
I think it's it's moving a little too
quick to to assume that this is all
about decisions just yet.
>> Yeah. It it it will not clarify what's
happening to jump into like a symbolic
human action orientation, though that's
an intuition that we all share. Really
quickly, Giacomo.
>> Yes. The [clears throat] choice of the
Dirac. It just for me to complete the
understand. Uh
It
This chapter here you said yes
this chapter here
looks at at
inference and kind of projects it that
happened after Rao Balder that happened
after these
initial and then kind of retro projects
it and says, "Oh look, what we did at
the beginning can actually be seen as a
specific case
of a predictive coding can be seen as a
of variational
of of of a variational free energy
optimization with a particular choice of
density.
Is this Is this actually
Is there Is this expositional
or is it actually something that people
actually do and they do it for
computational reasons because it allows
them to linearize a complicated problem
that might have to be solved iteratively
and can maybe be solved much more
economically from a computing point of
view?
>> Good question.
Short answer, you can make a predictive
model that just looked at the raw
differential.
>> Yeah.
>> you need to figure out some way to get
those raw differentials to a unified
loss function
and you would end up reconstructing
something like
precision or tension.
And then if you wanted to just take the
raw residuals or their squared residuals
modulated by attention or not, you'd get
some loss function. So you don't need to
use variational inference at all.
But this is a way where it's going to be
handled in a unified energy based frame.
>> Okay. So
there is it's in a way expositional.
It's saying keeping the general
framework going this particular approach
can be seen as a subclass of that for a
very specific choice of distributions of
of approximation
Sorry, approximative distributions.
>> Yeah, an implementation choice
>> choice Yeah.
>> for the broader idea of
prior
based updating.
>> Mhm.
>> And then again, there's multiple ways
that you could deal with how real-time
online updating happens.
But if you, for example, don't need to
do
real-time observation by observation
updating, if you only need batch,
>> Yes.
>> then there's going to be some other
implementations that are available.
So, there's multiple, but the but again,
these are
statistical algorithm-based choices.
We're steps away from like claims about
the retina.
So, it just shows how far away it is,
but then when they get conflated, and
then how far away claims about the
retina are from, you know, a group of
people deliberating about actions.
So, that's why it's good to just like
see where they're all at. And again, we
we look at at the um
overall book, it's like, wait, I mean,
isn't active inference about action? But
then we look and we go, well, no, it's
just going to get tucked in really
neatly to this belief updating
framework.
>> Mhm.
>> We don't need to obsess about action
because it's just a slightly different
kind of cause.
But it's like we're taking it so
seriously
that we're focusing on the generic
belief updating,
and action's included in that umbrella
that we're taking quite seriously,
rather than a bolt-on, because the whole
point is it isn't a bolt-on. It is part
of a unified approach.
Okay. Thank you. I'll stop recording.